SPEAKER:  GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME
TO THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
I'M TED WIDMER, DIRECTOR OF THE
JOHN W. KLUGE CENTER, A
ALL OF OUR SCHOLARS ARE HERE
TONIGHT.  I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO ASK YOU TO
SILENCE YOUR CELLPHONE AND
DEVICES AND AFTER THE PANEL
DISCUSSION, WE HAVE A Q AND A
WHICH WILL BE LIVE STREAMED AND
IF YOU CHOOSE TO ASK A QUESTION,
WHICH I HOPE YOU WILL, YOU GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LIBRARY
TO BROAD CAST YOURSELF.  SO
CHOOSE YOURCHOOSE YOUR QUESTION
CAREFULLY.
THIS EVENING, I WAS IN THE HUGE
AUDIENCE IN BROWN UNIVERSITY
WITH MY FORMER EMPLOYER, AND MY
ALMA MATER MARILYNNE ROBINSON,
WHEN GIVEN AN HONORARY DEGREE IN
2012, I WAS SO FAR THAT YOU
COULDN'T EVEN SEE HER.  I WILL
HAVE A MUCH BETTER SEAT.  AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE LIBRARY
SPECIALIZED IN AMERICAN HISTORY,
16TH, 17TH AND 18TH CENTURY AND
WE HAVE A SPECIAL THOUGHT OF
GRATITUDE FOR MARILYNNE TEACHING
THE VERY EARLY AMERICANS TO
OFTEN CONFINE TO THE SO-CALLED
HISTORY IN OUR SMALL PART OF THE
COUNTRY, OUR WONDERFUL BOOKS
HAVE ALWAYS FELT LIKE LETTERS
FROM A FRIEND.  AND SHE IS ALSO
OF COURSE A GREAT NATIONAL
FIGURE AND THAT'S WHY TONIGHT
MEANS SO MUCH.  WE HAVE SOME
EXTRAORDINARY LITERATE
PEOPLE HERE FOR HER IMPACT.  I
WILL SIMPLY CONCLUDE THE
WELCOMING REMARKS AND IT'S MY
PLEASURE FOR BEING HERE.  IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LIBRARY, AND OF
THE KLUGE CENTER, DR. JANE
MCAULIFFE.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER: THANK YOU, TED! IT'S SO
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU HERE
TONIGHT TO HELP US HONOR THE
WORK OF MARILYNNE ROBINSON, OUR
2016 LIBRARY OF CONGRESS PRIZE
FOR AMERICAN FICTION.
WELCOME TO THE LIBRARY!!
I WANT TO WELCOME THE AUDIENCE,
ESPECIALLY THE CONGRESSIONAL
UNITED CHURCH OF CHRIST IN IOWA
CITY, WHERE MARILYNNE SERVED AS
A DEACON FOR
MANY YEARS.
THE PRIZE IN AMERICAN FICTION
STANDS AS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
HONORS TO A LIVING AMERICAN
WRITER.  IT SEEKS TO COMMEND
STRONG, UNIQUE, ENDURING VOICES
THAT HAVE TOLD US SOMETHING NEW
ABOUT THE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WEREN'T AT
THE NATIONAL BOOK FESTIVAL LAST
SEPTEMBER WHEN THE LIBRARIAN OF
CONGRESS PRESENTED MARILYNNE
WITH THE PRIZE, I CAN TELL YOU
OUR WINNER HAD A LIVELY AND
INCITEFUL CONVERSATION WITH THE
FESTIVAL'S LITERARY DIRECTOR,
MARIE ARANA.
HOWEVER, NO SINGLE CONVERSATION
COULD CAPTURE THE POWER OF
MARILYNNE'S WORK, WHICH HAS
RECEIVED MANY OF THE COUNTRY'S
OTHER TOP HONORSﾗINCLUDING THE
PULITZER PRIZE, THE NATIONAL
BOOK CRITICS CIRCLE AWARD, AND
THE NATIONAL HUMANITIES MEDAL.
WHICH BRINGS US TO TONIGHT'S
EVENT, A CONVERSATION WE'RE
CALLING ﾓFICTION, FAITH, AND THE
IMAGINATION.ﾔ WE HAVE AN
AMAZING PANEL HERE WITH US,
INCLUDING TWO PULITZER PRIZE
WINNERSﾗGERALDINE BROOKS; AND
PAUL HARDING, WHO STUDIED UNDER
MARILYNNE AT THE FAMED IOWA
WRITERS WORKSHOP.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY THE
RENOWNED AMERICAN PHYSICIST,
ALAN LIGHT
MAN, AND STEVEN KNAPP WILL
MODERATE THE DISCUSSION.
AND OF COURSE, MARILYNNE IS HERE
TONIGHT WITH US AS WELL.  ONE
OF MARILYNNE'S GREATEST ADMIRERS
IS
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
HE COULDN'T JOIN US TONIGHT, BUT
HE HAS SENT A SPECIAL SURPRISE
MESSAGE FOR MARILYNNE.
PLEASE LET ME READ
OBAMA'S WORDS.
ﾓLIKE MOST AMERICANS, I FIRST
MET MARILYNNE ROBINSON ON THE
PAGES OF ONE OF HER
EXTRAORDINARY NOVELS. FOR ME, IT
WAS GILEAD, A BOOK I'D PICKED
UP AS I WAS BARNSTORMING ACROSS
IOWA DURING MY FIRST CAMPAIGN
FOR PRESIDENT. IN IT, I MET
FOLKS WHO WERE DECENT AND
GOOD-HEARTED, FULL OF THEIR OWN
COMPLEXITIES AND STRUGGLES.
I WAS ABSORBED INTO A STORY THAT
GRAPPLES EQUALLY WITH THE
BLOSSOMS AND THE THORNS IN OUR
RELATIONSHIPS - WITH EACH OTHER,
WITH OURSELVES, WITH OUR
CREATOR - AND STILL MANAGES TO
ACHIEVE A LEVEL OF GRACE THAT
WE'RE ALL
STRIVING FOR IN OUR OWN LIVES.
THAT'S WHAT MARILYNNE DOES SO
BRILLIANTLY. SHE NOT ONLY DRAWS
US INTO THE TEXTURE OF THE
PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES SHE
CREATES, BUT WRAPS US ALL
TOGETHER IN SOMETHING LARGER, A
PATCHWORK OF CHARACTERS AND
READERS AND AUTHOR; OF OUR
STRUGGLES AND OUR DELIGHTS; OF
OUR FAITH, OUR DOUBTS, OUR
REDEMPTION. AND IN DOING SO, SHE
ELEVATES OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE FULLY HUMAN.
THAT'S WHAT THE HIGHEST OF ART
CAN ACHIEVE. IT'S WHAT THE
GREATEST LIBRARY IN THE WORLD
SHOULD CELEBRATE. AND IT'S WHAT
MARILYNNE ROBINSON SEEMS TO
RADIATE EVERY TIME SHE SITS DOWN
TO WRITE.
SO I WANT TO ONCE AGAIN
CONGRATULATE MY FRIEND,
MARILYNNE, ON HER DISTINGUISHED
AWARD. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR GATHERING TOGETHER
TONIGHT FOR SOMETHING THAT, FOR
MARILYNNE, MIGHT BE AN EVEN
GREATER REWARD A THOUGHTFUL,
LIVELY CONVERSATION ON SOME OF
THE TOPICS DEAR TO ALL OF OUR
HEARTS. HAVE A GREAT NIGHT,
EVERYONE.ﾔ ON THAT LOVELY NOTE,
FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA, PLEASE LET
ME TURN THE EVENING OVER TO
STEVEN KNAPP.  [APPLAUSE].
IT'S A PLEASURE TO WELCOME YOU.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATECENTER FOR POETRY AND THE
KLUGE CENTER AND THOSE WHO ARE
RESPECTIVELY HOSTING THIS EVENT
HERE AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
AND I WANT TO SAY HOW PROUD I AM
TO BE MODERATING SUCH A
DISTINGUISHED PANEL.  AS YOU
HAVE ALREADY HEARD, I DO THINK
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB OPENING THE DISCUSSION
FOR THE PANEL.  I WANT TO SAY A
FEW THINGS BEFORE I POSE
QUESTIONS TO THE PANELISTS.  OUR
TOPIC IS BETWEEN FAITH AND
IMAGINATION AND
INFLICTION IN THE WAY MARILYNNE
ROBINSON HAS THE COVENANT
CONCEPTION
OF BRACE AND DOES SO IN PART,
THROUGH THE ELABORATION AND
TRANSPOSITION THROUGH THE MOST
FAMOUS DEPICTION IN
DEFYING GRACE
IN THE GOSPEL OF LUKE.  FATHER
GRANTS THE REQUEST.  GOES OFF.
AND SQUANDERS THROUGH LIVING AND
RETURNS HOME IMPOVERISHED AND
DISGRACED.  FATHER WANTS TO
FORGIVE HIM.  BUT AMAZING LY
THERE WAS A PARTY IN HIS HONOR.
HIS SON WHO WAS OBEDIENT OBJECTS
TO THE SPECIAL TREATMENT
AND EXPLAINING THAT THIS LEVEL
WAS YOURS WAS LOST AND NOW
FOUND.
IT PORTRAYED ROBINSON'S
TRILOLOGY.  HOME BEGINS WITH A
CHILD AND THE FATHER.  AND THIS
TIME A YOUNGER SISTER AND NOT A
BROTHER.  AND MISPLACED TRUST OF
THE FIANC￉E WHO WAS NOT GREETED
BY ANY SORT OF PARTY AND HAD
THE OBEDIENT CARE GIVER OF HER
ALIEN FATHER,
PRESBYTERIAN ROBERT.
AND OLDER BROTHER JACK SOON
COMES HOME AS WELL AND DIFFICULT
AND NEVER QUITE FINISHED
RECONCILIATION WITH THE FATHER.
JACK, THE FATHER'S FAVORITE
DESPITE HIS DELINQUENT CHILDHOOD
LEAVES AFTER THE ACT.  AND IN
THE SIN OF HIS FATHER'S EYES AND
KNOWN REDEMPTION.  MARRIAGE TO
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN OF A
MIXED RACE SON.  JACK'S WIFE SON
ROBERT SHOWS UP AT THE FAMILY
HOME AFTER JACK HAS LEFT.  AND
GLORY AND NOW THE FATHER FINDS
OUT THE TRUTH.  AND ENDS WITH
GLORY IN THE OWN IMAGINATION.
THE DAY JACK'S SON ROBERT WILL
RETURN TO THE HOMESTEAD TRULY
ANSWERING HIS FATHER'S PRAYERS
IN A WAY THAT JACK NEVER
ANSWERED HIS OWN PRAYERS.  AND
THAT IS THE LONG DELAYED BUT
MERCIFUL EXPRESSION OF
GOD'S GRACE.  NOW IT SCRATCHES
THE SURFACE OF THE GRACE AND
PROTAGONIST OF THE NOVEL "JOHN
AIMS" AND RELIGIOUSLY LESS
EDUCATED YOUNGER BROTHER LAYA,
AND THE THIRD NOVEL.  A LOOK AT
THE EXPLORATION AND GRACE.  IT'S
NOT JUST THE PERSONAL ANGLE
FROM WHICH SHE APPROACHES IT,
BUT THE SUBTLE WAY IN WHICH SHE
CONNECTS THE STORIES WITH
MOVEMENTS AND EVENTS THAT HAVE
FORMED OR AROUND THEM.
ABOLITIONISM, CIVIL WAR, DUST
BOWL, GREAT DEPRESSION, THE
BEGINNING OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.  THE TRILOLOGY, THESE
ARE HISTORY, AND SOMETIMES HAUNT
THE PRESENT AND SOMETIMES
VIOLENTLY IN THE SURFACE OF THE
NARRATIVE.  SO TONIGHT I WOULD
LIKE TO START A DISCUSSION.  AND
I WOULD START WITH YOU
GERALDINE BROOKS.  OUR TOPIC IS
"FICTION FAITH AND THE
IMAGINATION."  AS
I JUST SUGGESTED, ONE OF THE
FASCINATING ELEMENTS OF
MARILYNNE ROBINSON'S FICTION IS
THE WAY SHE WEAVES TOGETHER
RELIGIOUS CONCERNS AND A RICH
HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND THERE IS
A SENSE IN THE
LOVELY.
SPEAKER:  ROBINSON'S NOVEL IN
THE NEAR PAST IS NOT
TRADITIONALLY WHAT WOULD BE
DESCRIBED AS HISTORICAL FICTION.
IT'S LIKE WHAT I LIKE TO THINK
OF HENRY JAMES' DESIGNATED SAFE
SON.  BECAUSE JAMES HAD ANY
ATTEMPT TO WRITE ABOUT A PERIOD
MORE THAN 50 YEARS REMOVED FROM
ONE'S OWN AND SHOULD NOT BE
ATTEMPTED BECAUSE THE OLD
CONSCIOUSNESS WOULD BE TO LIST
TO US.  ACTUALLY IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, IF YOU'RE A NOVELIST
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE JOURNEY OF
YOUR LIFE, THAT 50-YEAR WINDOW
ADDED TO THE 50 YEARS OF YOUR
OWN EXPERIENCE GIVES YOU AN
ENTIRE CENTURY IN WHICH TO PRY
YOUR TRADE.  WHICH IS NOT
UNGENEROUS TO IT AT TIMES.  AND
I THINK IN THE CASE OF
MARILYNNE'S NOVEL, THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.  BECAUSE I CAN'T
IMAGINE GULIAD SET OFF TO 1960.
I THINK IT'S MUCH BETTER SET IN
THE SLIGHTLY MORE DISTANT PAST.
PERHAPS, IF YOU WANTED TO LOOK
FOR A DIVIDING LINE, IT WOULD BE
BEFORE, AND COULD POSSIBLY HAVE
A TIME MAGAZINE COVER THAT SAID
IS GOD DEAD?  I THINK YOU'RE IN
A TIME PERIOD WHERE THE
MATERIALISTIC SKEPTICISM HAS NOT
BEEN SOCIAL FABRIC OF AT LEAST
THE ENGLISH SPEAKING WORLD TO
THE EXTENT IT HAPPENED AFTER THE
'60S AND IT
REMINDS ME OF OUR WONDERFUL
ESSAY BY JAMES WARD IN HIS
COLLECTION IN THE BOOK "ESTATES"
AND WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT THE
NOVEL ITSELF WAS, IN A
WAY, CORROSIVE TO FAITH.
BECAUSE THE NOVEL IS IN AS-IF
FORM.  YOU'RE CREATING AS IF.
BUT YOU'RE NOT CREATING
CERTAINTY.  AND HE TALKS ABOUT
THE VERY FEW BILLION WRITERS
THAT ARE ABLE TO RETAIN
RELIGIOUS ELEMENTS IN THEIR FIX
WITH THE TRUE BELIEF IN FICTION
ITSELF AND THE PURPOSES OF
FICTION.  AND HE SINGLES OUT
WOLF AND TALKS ABOUT GENTLE
VALUE THAT SHE HAS BETWEEN
RELIGION AND I THINK THAT
MARILYNNE ROBINSON IS NOT A
GENTLE ONE, BUT PASSIONATE.
AND I THINK IT WORKS VERY
BEAUTIFULLY.  BECAUSE SHE SEES
THE MYSTICAL AND THE RELIGIOUS
IN THE ORDINARY.  IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE A VIRGIN BIRTH TO BE
WONDERFUL.  BECAUSE ANY BIRTH IS
A MIRACLE.  YOUNG SON SO
BEAUTIFULLY EVOKED AND
DEMONSTRATED AND I THINK OF THAT
WONDERFUL PASSAGE WHERE AIMS
REFLECTS THAT LIFE IS CONSTANT.
AND WE JUST TURN OVER IN IT.
AND EVERY DAY IS ONE DAY.  AND
ONCE YOU HAVE THAT THOUGHT, THEN
WHO NEEDS TO ARGUE WHETHER THE
WORLD WAS CREATED IN SIX DAYS?
IT BECOMES A MAGNIFICENT
IRRELEVANCY.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU ALSO HAVE THE SPECULATIVE
NOVEL ABOUT THE ALTERNATE
REALITY AND SCIENTISTS IN RECENT
YEARS, AND THIS LEADS TO THE
CORROSIVE MATERIALISM THAT, YOU
KNOW, WAS MENTIONED.  YOU NOTICE
HOW THE THOUGHTS OF CRITICAL
RELIGION HAVE EVIDENCE-BASED
REASONING WITH CONTRAST AND
RELIANCE ON FAITH.  AND
EXPANDING THE SCIENCE IN FAITH,
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?  DOES
FAITH PLAY A ROLE IN SCIENCE?
IF SO, WHAT KIND OF FAITH?  HOW
DO YOU KEEP THAT IN YOUR OWN
IMAGINATION IN THE WORLD OF
RELIGION AND SCIENCE?
SPEAKER:  I THINK FOR ME FAITH
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN'T
PROVE.  AND THE FOCUS IS THAT
EVERYTHING THAT SCIENCE
BELIEVES, IT CAN PROVE.  AND
NOTHING THAT RELIGION
BELIEVES
IT CAN PROVE.  I THINK THAT
SCIENCE AND RELIGION HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT METHODS OF
ARRIVING AT THEIR BELIEFS.  I
THINK THERE IS
FAITH AND RELIGION AND BOTH.
FAITH IS VERY VERY FUNDAMENTAL
FOR WHAT SCIENTISTS HAVE.  IT'S
SOMETHING THAT ONE MIGHT CALL
THE CENTRAL DOCTRINE OF SCIENCE.
AND THE CENTRAL DOCTRINE OF
SCIENCE IS
THAT THE UNIVERSE IS THOUGHTFUL
AND LOGICAL.  IT'S A DOCTRINE
THAT WE SCIENTISTS LEARN AS
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND WE MAY NOT
LEARN IT CONSCIOUSLY.
BUT IT'S SORT OF IN THE AIR.
INTO THE SKIN.  IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL WORKING BELIEF THAT
SCIENTISTS HAVE.  AND IT'S A
BELIEF THAT CAN'T BE PROVED.  IT
HAS TO BE
TAKEN ON FAITH.
BECAUSE NO MATTER HOW MUCH
SCIENCE KNOWS AND NO MATTER HOW
SUCCESSFUL OUR THEORIES ARE,
THEY'RE INCOMPLETE.  THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHICH
MARILYNNE HAS TALKED ABOUT.  AND
THINGS THAT SCIENCE DOESN'T
KNOW.
AND WE
CAN'T BE CERTAIN THAT ALL PARTS
OF UNIVERSE ARE LOGICAL.  WE
DON'T KNOW IF NEW PARTS OF
TOMORROW WILL BE LAWFUL AND
LOGICAL.  WE CAN'T BE CERTAIN.
SO THE BELIEF AND THE CENTRAL
DOCTRINE THAT EVERYTHING IN THE
PHYSICAL UNIVERSE IS LAWFUL AND
LOGICAL, THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS TO BE TAKEN ON FAITH.
SPEAKER:  SO YOU MENTIONED
SPECIAL INTEREST AND RELATION
BETWEEN PHYSICAL AND
NON-PHYSICAL PERCEPTIONS OF
REALITY.  CAN YOU TELL US A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT THAT?  AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT YOU JUST THINK
ABOUT THE NON-PHYSICAL.
SPEAKER:  WELL, MARILYNNE HAS
WRITTEN WUFLY ABOUT
SCIENCE AND RELIGION.  AND SHE
SUGGESTS IN HER WRITING THAT WE
MAKE TOO MUCH OF A DEAL OUT OF
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PHYSICAL AND NON-PHYSICAL.  BUT
WE MAKE TOO BIG OF A DISTINCT
FOR WHAT SHE SAYS.  AND PLEASE
CORRECT ME, I DON'T KNOW IF I AM
GIVING IT WRONG.  BUT SHE SAYS
THAT BECAUSE THE KNOWLEDGE OF
SCIENCE ABOUT THE PHYSICAL
UNIVERSE IS
INCOMPLETE, THAT WE CAN'T
CONFIDENTLY MAKE AN OPPOSITION
OF THE PHYSICAL UNIVERSE BECAUSE
WE DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
PHYSICAL UNIVERSE.  WELL, I
AGREE WITH PART OF THAT.  AND
NOT ALL OF IT.  I DO AGREE THAT
THE KNOWLEDGE OF SCIENCE ABOUT
THE PHYSICAL UNIVERSE IS
INCOMPLETE.  BUT FOR ME AS BOTH
A SCIENTIST AND A HUMANIST AND
IF I CAN SAY, A SPIRITUAL
PERSON, I THINK THAT THE
DISTINCT BETWEEN THE PHYSICAL
AND THE NON-PHYSICAL UNIVERSES
IS VERY IMPORTANT.  AND I THINK
THAT THERE ARE EXPERIENCES THAT
WE HAVE AND PROBABLY EVERYBODY
HERE HAS HAD THEM.  AND YOU CAN
CALL THEM TRANSCENDING
EXPERIENCES.  BUT SCIENCE WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN EVEN IN
PRINCIPLE, WILL NEVER BE ABLE
TO FULLY COMPREHEND.  YOU CAN
HOOK 100 BILLION ELECTRODES TO
MY NEURONS AND MEASURE EVERY
ELECTRICAL OUTPUT OF EACH
NEURON.  BUT THAT WILL NOT
EXPLAIN THE EXPERIENCE THAT I
HAVE IN LOOKING OR FEELING LIKE
THERE IS SOMETHING LARGER THAN
MYSELF.  THAT, TO ME, IS PART OF
THE NON-PHYSICAL UNIVERSE.  IF
WE BELIEVE IN GOD,
IF GOD EXISTS, IN EVERY
RELIGION THAT I KNOW OF HAS A
CONCEPTION OF GOD, IN WHICH GOD
DOES NOT LOVE IN TIME AND SPACE.
GOD IS NOT SUBJECT TO LAWS AND
RULES.  SO GOD WOULD ALSO BE A
PART OF WHAT I WOULD CALL THE
NON-PHYSICAL UNIVERSE.  ON THE
OTHER HAND, I AM A STRONG
SUBSCRIBER TO THE CENTRAL
DOCTRINE OF SCIENCE.
HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT.  AND I
DO THINK THERE IS A VAST RANGE
OF PHENOMENON THAT SCIENCE DOES
UNDERSTAND AND SCIENCE CAN
EXPLAIN AND IS SUBJECT TO THE
LAWS THAT WE UNDERSTAND.  AND I
CALL THAT THE PHYSICAL UNIVERSE.
SO I NEED TO HAVE A DISTINCT
BETWEEN THOSE TWO UNIVERSES TO
LIVE A LIFE BOTH AS A SCIENTIST
AND AS A HUMANIST.
SPEAKER:  TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
ABOUT HOW YOUR INTERESTS FIT
INTO THAT, YOUR INTEREST IN
FICTION ITSELF TO SUPPOSE THAT
DISTINCTION.
SPEAKER:  WELL, I WROTE A BOOK,
A NOVEL CALLED "MR. G" AND THAT
IS A LOWER CASE G STANDING FOR
GOD AND IT'S A BOOK THAT TELLS
THE STORY OF CREATION FROM A
POINT OF VIEW OF GOD.  AND GOD
IS THE NARRATOR OF THE BOOK.
GOD HAS AN UNCLE AND AN AUNT WHO
ARE ALWAYS CRITICIZING HIM FOR
NOT GETTING THINGS RIGHT.  AND
THE UNIVERSE THAT GOD CREATES IS
A
LAWFUL UNIVERSE.  GOD CONSIDERS
THE POSSIBILITY OF ENTERING THE
UNIVERSE AND INTERVENING AND
PERFORMING MIRACLES WHICH COULD
BE UNLAWFUL AND DILATE THE
CENTRAL DOCTRINE OF SCIENCE.
AND GOD CHOOSES NOT TO DO THAT.
AND FOR ME, THIS WAS AN
IMPORTANT EXPLORATION FROM ME TO
THINK ABOUT HOW THE PHYSICAL
AND THE SPIRITUAL UNIVERSES
COULD EXIST IN HARMONY WITH EACH
OTHER WITHOUT
ANY CON  TRADICTION.
SPEAKER:  WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
THE IMAGINATION NEGOTIATES THE
PATH BETWEEN THE PHYSICAL AND
NON-PHYSICAL INFORMATION AND
EXPERIENCE.  BY THE WAY, I I
WANT
TO SHIFT
TO A PERSONAL
TAKE ON WHY THIS IS TRUE.  AND
AS A TEACHER, OF COURSE, I WANT
YOU TO SAY WHAT THAT EXPERIENCE
WAS LIKE.  AND DOES THE
INTERSECTION OF FAITH AND
IMAGINATION ALSO PLAY A ROLE IN
THE CLASSROOM, IN HER CLASSROOM?
SPEAKER:  WELL I CAN SAY IT
WAS A GOOD EXPERIENCE.  AND I
HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF HAVING
BEEN A DRUMMER IN A ROCK
BAND FOR MANY YEARS.  AND THE
ROCK BAND BROKE UP AND IT BECAME
TIME FOR ME TO GET A JOB.  AND
FOR THAT PROSPECT, I THOUGHT I
ABOUT JUST GO TO GRAD SCHOOL.
AND A LOT OF WRITERS, PEOPLE
BECOME WRITERS.
AND I WAS A READER.  AND I
THOUGHT OF MYSELF AS A WRITER
BEFORE I WROTE ANYTHING.  I
WOULD WALK AROUND SAYING I HAVE
A WRITER IN THE FAMILY AND I
FINALLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE A FICTION WRITING CLASS
IN COLLEGE AT SARATOGA.  AND
JUST BY THE LUCK OF LOTTERY, I
SIGNED UP FOR A CLASS AND
MARILYNNE ROBINSON WALKED IN.
AND WITHIN TEN MINUTES OF HER
STARTING TO TALK ABOUT THE LIFE
OF THE MIND, SPIRITUALITY,
HISTORY, I KNEW THE LIFE I
WANTED FOR MY OWN MIND.  TRY TO
EMULATE THAT.  AND LUCKY ENOUGH
TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW HER UP TO
THE WRITERS WORKSHOP AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF IOWA AND I THINK
THE DAY I FOUND OUT I GOT INTO
IOWA IS THE DAY THAT I FOUND OUT
SHE WON THE LIVING AWARD AND I
WAS NOT GOING TO BE IN IOWA.
AND SO I HAD TO MAKE MY BREAKS.
AND SO SHE TAUGHT A CLASS IN THE
OLD TESTAMENT AT THE
CONGREGATIONAL CHURCH IN IOWA
CITY.  AND I THINK THAT WAS THE
FIRST TIME THAT I SAID THE OLD
TESTAMENT WITH HER.  AND I USE
THE ANALOGY BEFORE.  THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SITTING IN
THE SEMINAR ROOM AND STUDYING
PARADISE LAST AND SITTING IN A
SEMINAR ROOM WITH JOHN NELSON.
IT REALLY IS THAT PROFOUND.
AND SHE TAUGHT ME FELLOWSHIP
AND TREAT OTHER HUMAN BEINGS
WHICH IS A SCEPTIC.  AS A
SOPHOMORE, I SAT IN A SKEPTICISM
CLASS.
GRANTING OTHER PEOPLE WITH
RESPECT IN A WAY LIKE RUNNING
INTO THE BRICK WALL THAT YOU CAN
EVER RUN INTO.  AND I THINK
THAT'S ALL OF THESE THINGS SORT
OF ALIGNED TELL US THE WAY THAT
SHE TEACHES, THE WAY THAT SHE
THINKS AND THE WAY SHE MODELS
THE LIFE OF THE MIND.  THE
INTENSITY AND THE HONESTY OF IT.
AND SHE OFTEN SAYS THAT YOUR JOB
AS A FICTION WRITER IS TO WRITE
SENTENCES THAT ARE TRUE.  WHICH
IS CONTRADICTORY BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF ANECDOTAL THINGS
THAT THE FICTION WRITER PUTS ON
STAGE.  I'M A FICTION WRITER AND
IN THE PAST I'M TOLD I'M A
PATHOLOGICAL LIAR.  AND SO THEN
OVER THE YEARS, I HAD NEVER
CONSIDERED RELIGION.  I GREW UP
INNOCENT IN RELIGION.  INNOCENT
I WOULD SAY IN THE STRICT SENSE
OF I DID NOT GO TO CHURCH.  MY
FAMILY WAS NEITHER
ANTAGONISTIC WITH RELIGION OR
SYMPATHETIC WITH IT.  AND AT THE
TIME ADMIRING MARILYNNE AS MUCH
AS I DID.  IF I WAS TO ASK HER
WHAT THE SOURCE OF HER ARTISTIC
AND INTELLECTUAL SPHISTICATION
WAS, SHE WOULD SAY HER
RELIGION.  AND FAITH.  AND I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE SOMETHING TO TALK ABOUT
WITH HER WHEN I CORNERED HER FOR
COFFEE.  WHICH IS ANOTHER
STORY.  BUT I READ INSTITUTES
AND CHURCH  PRAGMATICS AND WE
STILL HAVE THESE WONDERFUL
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVEN'T ENDED
YET.  AND SO I THINK WE ARE ALL
ORDAINED TO FELLOWSHIP.  AND I
THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS REALLY STRUCK ME DEEPLY
AND NEVER STOPPED RESONATING.
AND WHAT THE INTERCEPTION OF HER
FAITH AND THE IMAGINATION.  I
DON'T KNOW THAT SHE WOULD MAKE A
DISTINCTION.  JUST IN TERMS OF
-- I THINK SHE HAS WRITTEN ABOUT
THIS.  IN HER FAITH -- I'M JUST
PARAPHRASING.  SHE THINKS OF
HER FAITH AS THE GREAT GIVING IN
PSYCHOLOGICAL TERMS.  IT'S A
GIFT.  SHE TAKES AN EXALTED VIEW
OF
EXPERIENCE.  SHE NEVER OPENLY
SAID IN CLASS.  BUT SHE EMBODIES
THE VIRTUES OF THE BEST PART OF
HER OWN FAITH AND GRACE.  AND
INSPIRES HER STUDENTS.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  THAT IS
TRUE.  I DO WANT TO SAY AS A
SOMETIMES SCHOLAR, YOU WOULD NOT
HAVE ENJOYED A SEMINAR WITH
JOHN.  IT WOULDN'T BE THE SAME.
SPEAKER:  MAYBE NOT.
SHAKESPEARE.
SPEAKER:  SO, I'M REALLY STRUCK
BY WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT -- MAYBE
YOU CAN CORRECT THIS AT SOME
POINT.  BUT MARILYNNE ROBINSON'S
DISTINCTION BETWEEN FAITH AND
IMAGINATION.  I WANT TO HEAR
WHAT EACH THE PANELISTS HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT QUESTION.  HOW
CLOSE IS THE RELATION BETWEEN
FAITH AND IMAGINATION?  AND HOW
DO WE INTERVENE AND SORT SORT OF
SORT OF EXPERIENCE
THAT?  WE COULD SAY THAT ONE
HAS AN EXTREMELY INTIMATE
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE CHARACTERS
THAT SHE PICKS.  AND SOMETIMES
THAT LINE, YOU KNOW, BECOMES
DIFFICULT.  AND I MENTIONED THE
MOMENT
AT THE END OF HOME WHERE
IMAGINED DECADES OF THE FUTURE.
WHERE GRACE WILL OCCUR.  AND
WHO KNOWS WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING
ON?  IT'S A GESTURE OF FAITH.
IT'S A MOMENT OF IMAGINING.  AND
I WOULD LIKE TO START, WHOEVER
WANTS TO START WITH INTEREST OF
TAKING THIS UP.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE DISTINCTION
AND SIMILARITIES
OVERLAP THE FAITH AND
IMAGINATION?
SPEAKER:  I FEEL SORRY FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE ANY KIND
OF RELIGIOUS EDUCATION.  I HAVE
HAD TWO SEPARATE ONES.
PREFERABLY BETWEEN THREE.  I WAS
RAISED ROMAN CATHOLIC IN A VERY
TRADITIONAL IRISH
STYLE.
EDUCATED BY NUNS.  AND I THINK
THE GREAT GIFT OF THAT HAS
ABSTRACT THOUGHT.  BECAUSE WHEN
YOU TELL A 7-YEAR-OLD THAT THERE
ARE THREE PERSONS AND ONE GOD,
YOU ARE REALLY OPENING UP THE
IDEA OF ABSTRACT.  IN A VERY
PARTICULAR WAY.  AND THE OTHER
THING I AM GRATEFUL FOR IS THE
SENSE OF METAPHOR THAT YOU GET.
I REMEMBER BENEDICTION AND THE
LONG LIST OF
WAYS THAT YOU CAN REALLY HAVE
THE STAR OF THE SEEDS AND THE
ROWS.  AND I THINK THAT RELIGION
OPENS YOU UP TO
IMAGINATION.  AND LATER ON IN
LIFE, WHAT SOME SAY IS A MUCH
MORE HARD HEADED PIECE OF
BUSINESS.  AND ALSO STUDIED
ISLAM VERY CLOSELY AND THE
CORRESPONDENCE LIVING AMONG THE
WOMEN OF ISLAM WHO MADE A VERY
DIFFERENT CHOICE TO CONVEY THE
ORTHODOX VERSION OF FAITH AND I
FOUND VERY CONFOUNDING AND I
WANTED TO EXPLORE HOW THEY HAD
DONE THAT.  AND I LOVED WHAT
MARILYNNE ONCE SAID.  SHE HAD AN
ECSTATIC RELIGIOUS EXPERIENCE
AND SAID IT WOULD BE WASTED BY
ME.  BECAUSE SHE FINDS THE OLD
MARY SO LUMINOUS AND I THINK
THAT IS WHAT A RELIGION
IMAGINATION GIVES YOU THE
SENSE OF NOTICING.  AND THAT'S
WHAT I LIKE JEWISH PRODESTANT SO
MUCH BECAUSE IT'S GRATEFUL FOR
NOTICING.  AND AND THE
BREAD AND THE RAIN AND YOUR
CHILDREN.  EVERY SINGLE FRIDAY
NIGHT.  AND THAT'S A GOOD HABIT
OF MINE TO
GET INTO I THINK.
SPEAKER:  I THINK OF FAITH AS
BELIEF IN THE UNSEEN.  AND TO
ME, THAT IS VERY
CLOSE TO THE IMAGINATION.
BECAUSE THE IMAGINATION, WE ARE
CREATING THINGS IN OUR MINDS
THAT ARE --
THAT MAY NOT BE CONCRETE.  THAT
MAY NOT BE VISIBLE.  AND YET,
THEY ARE IDEAS THAT MOTIVATE US,
THAT PROVOKE US, THAT STIMULATE
US.  AND SO THAT IS THE
CONNECTION THAT I SEE AT A
REALLY LOW LEVEL BETWEEN FAITH
AND IMAGINATION.
SPEAKER:  YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
ACT OF CREATING HEART AND THE
ACT OF CULTIVATING IN
IMAGINATION WILL DISCIPLINE THE
OBSERVATION.  AND DISCIPLINE
OBEDIENCE TO OBSERVE THINGS AS
INTENSELY AND AS CLOSELY AS
POSSIBLE.  AND RENDER THEM OUT
OF THE PAGE WITH AESTHETIC
PRESSURE ON THEM IN THE CASE OF
FICTION, IT'S AN ACT OF
DEVOTION.  AND AN ACT OF
OBEDIENCE AND AN ACT OF PRAYER.
AND WITH THAT
BEAUTIFUL KIND OF COMMERCE
WITHIN YOUR MIND.  AND
EPISTICOLOGICAL AND YOU HAVE THE
METAPHORS AND THEY TOPPLE AND
YOU BUILD THEM UP AGAIN.  AND
YOU HAVE THE BOOK THAT GOES OUT
INTO THE WORLD.  AND IN WRITING
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THE BOOK IS
GOING TO INTERACT WITH OTHER
PEOPLE AND THEIR LIVES AND GOING
TO HAVE AGAIN, A FELLOWSHIP.
BUT ALSO, THE ACT OF FAITH, YOU
KNOW, THESE
WORKS OF ART THAT HAVE TO BE
MADE IN GOOD FAITH BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO GO OUT AND
AFFECT PEOPLES' LIVES.
SPEAKER:  NOW IT OCCURS TO ME IN
WHICH ONE OF THE WAYS THAT IT
INTERPLAYS WITH MARILYNNE
ROBINSON AND FAITH IN PARTICULAR
IS THE WAY THAT PERSONS ENGAGE
WITH EACH OTHER AND IT'S ALMOST
LIKE YOU ENGAGE
OTHER PEOPLE THROUGH BEEN A
AN AN ACT OF FAITH AND THERE WAS
A CONNECTION OF IMMIGRATION
BETWEEN FATHER AND GRANDFATHER.
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS
NEW WORLD.  AND FEEL THE WAY
INTO THE ALIEN WORLD OF JOHN
AIMS THEOLOGY.  OR EVERYONE IS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND JACK.  AND
DOESN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND
HIMSELF.  AND CAN ENGAGE HIMSELF
AND THE CONSTANT SENSE OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH MYSTERY WHEN YOU
ARE DEALING WITH PERSONS.  IT'S
NOT JUST THE SUPER NATURAL.
IT'S THE EVERYDAY EVENT OF HUMAN
RELATIONS AND BECOMES AN
OCCASION FOR FAITH.  AND
IMAGINING ENGAGEMENT WITH
OTHERS.  AND GERALDINE TALKS
ABOUT GRAND SUBJECTS HERE.  AND
THERE IS ALSO THE ELEMENT OF
WHIT AND HUMOR THAT YOU WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU DIDN'T
IGNORE.
SPEAKER:  YEAH.
SPEAKER:  IF YOU CAN TAKE US A
LITTLE THROUGH THAT.
SPEAKER:  SO
YEAH, I THINK EVERYBODY IS
GRANDER AND THE ACHIEVEMENT AND
THE PENETRATION INTO WHAT
MARILYNNE APPROVES.
BUT IT'S A VERY FUNNY BOOK.  AND
I THINK OF SOME OF THE
CHARACTERIZATIONS IN
HOUSEKEEPING WHERE EVERYBODY IS
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND EACH
OTHER.  AND IT'S JUST WONDERFUL
SENSE OF THE ESSENTIAL
KNOWLEDGEABILITY OF EVEN THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE CLOSEST TO
AND YOU LOVE THE MOST, AND WHY
DID THEY DO THAT.  THINGS THAT
JUST MADE ME SMILE AND CHUCKLE
AND GOOD WOMEN HAD A FINGER BURN
COMING TO SEE THE CHILDREN WITH
THE BEST WILL IN THE WORLD SO
DELICIOUS DELICIOUSLY.  AND MY
OTHER FAVORITE SCENE, THE
CHARACTERIZATION OF AIMS' FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER WHEN THEY ARE
VERY, VERY ANGRY WITH EACH OTHER
AND EVERY SENTENCE ENDS.  YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT THE WHIT IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD NOT BE
OVERLOOKED OR UNDER ESTIMATED.
SPEAKER:  AND IN THE CLASSROOM?
SPEAKER:  ABSOLUTELY.
YES.
WICKED ISN'T THE RIGHT WORD.
BUT UNDER STATED, PROFOUND.
YES.  YES.  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  YOU KNOW ANOTHER ONE,
I TALKED ABOUT THE FEEL OF
GRACE.  BUT THERE IS ANOTHER
THEME THAT SORT OF RUNS THROUGH
THESE NOVELS AND IT HAS AN
INTEREST FOR OUTSIDERS.  AND I
THINK PAUL MENTIONED THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND ESPECIALLY FIGURED
AS THE CARE WITH THE STRANGER
AND THE ORPHAN AND SO ON.  CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ELEMENT OF THE FICTION?  YOU CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
PERHAPS?
SPEAKER:  I THINK IT BEGINS WITH
THE LIVES THAT SHE HAS TAKEN
THE TIME TO DEVOTE HER ATTENTION
TO.
AND AS YOU SAY THAT,
PARTICULARLY THINKING ABOUT
LILA IN THIS CASE, WHERE SHE IS
POOR.
SHE IS AN
ORPHAN.  AND SHE IS WHEEPING IN
THE ALIEN CORNER.
AND JUST BY THE ACT OF DEVOTING
INSTEAD OF LAVISHING THAT
QUALITY OF ATTENTION AND THE
REMARKS IT'S LIKE THE ACT OF
OBEDIENCE, THE ACT OF FAITH, THE
ACT OF IMAGINATION BEING A
GESTURE OF FELLOWSHIP TOWARDS
THE LIVES THAT WOULD NOT BE
OTHERWISE NOTED.  AND THIS KIND
OF LAW THAT KIND OF GETS SWEPT
INTO THE CORNERS BY BECAUSE CALL
OF THE KINGS AND THE PRINCES
AND THE
JUDGES ARE UP TO NO GOOD.
IF ONE THING MAKES THE LORD
ANGRY, IT'S NOT TAKEN
CARE OF.
THE HUNGRY AND THE ORPHAN.
SPEAKER:  SO IN THE TRILOLOGY,
THERE IS AN ABSENT VERSION OF
THIS THAT HAUNTS NARRATIVES AND
ONLY SURFACES EXPLICITLY, AND
THAT IS THE RACIAL DIVISION OF
THE COUNTRY.  AND WHERE EVERYONE
IS SO STRONGLY FOCUSED ON OUR
CULTURE TODAY.  AND OF COURSE IT
COMES IN AND OUT.  AND IT'S
ALWAYS IN THE BACKGROUND.  AND
EVEN GOING BACK TO THE TENSION
BETWEEN THE FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER.  AND THE DIVERSION
OF QUESTION OF ELEMENTS.  I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO SAY ANYTHING.  BUT YOUR
SENSE OF HOW THE RACIAL DYNAMICS
PLAY OUT IN ALL OF THESE
WRITINGS.
ANYONE WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT?
SPEAKER:  I THINK THAT IS
PERHAPS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENT OF GILIAD.  IT'S A
STORY ABOUT LOVE AND IT'S A VERY
INTIMATE PORTRAYAL OF LOVE.
BUT IT HAS MANAGED TO DIGEST
THIS
ELEPHANT WHICH IS WHO ARE YOU
AND DEMAND SOMETHING OF
YOU AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTION.  AND
TALK ABOUT THE SENSE OF URGENCY.
AND THAT IS A GREAT
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
QUESTION THAT
THE CIVIL WAR ASKED OF
EVERYBODY THAT WAS REQUIRED TO
LIVE THROUGH IT.
WHO ARE YOU?  HOW DID YOU
RESPOND AND I WORKED FOR A WHILE
NOT FAR FROM HERE IN A
QUAKERTOWN WHICH WAS SETTLED IN
1733 BY QUAKERS AND ONE OF THE
FEW PLACES WHERE BLACKS COULD
LIVED UNHARASSED BY THE CIVIL
WAR.  AND YOUNG MEN IN THAT TOWN
FACED THE GREATER CHOICE.
VIOLENCE OR SLAVERY.  AND SOME
OF THE YOUNG MEN IN THAT TOWN
MADE THE CHOICE TO TAKE UP ARMS
AND FIGHT AGAINST SLAVERY.  AND
THAT MEANT THEY WERE OUT OF
MEETING AND HAD A TOWN.  AND I
THINK THE CHOICES THAT WE MAKE
AS INDIVIDUALS ARE REALLY NARROW
AND IF SO, EXQUISITELY GIFTED
AND EXPLAINED WHO MAKES WHAT
CHOICE AND WHAT ARE THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF IT.
SPEAKER:  SO
SOMEBODY MENTIONED EARLY THE
LUMINOUS CHARACTER OF THE
ORDINARY COMING THROUGH THE
TEACHING AND COMING THROUGH THE
FICTION.  WE DON'T TALK MUCH
ABOUT THE WATER PERVASIVE ROLE
OF WHETHER SEASONAL CHANGE OR
THE INTERFAITH CERTAINLY, YOU
KNOW, THINGS HAPPENING ON THE
EDGE OF TOWN IN A REAL SETTING.
AND THEN THE WAY THAT CHARACTERS
MOVE THROUGH THAT LAST PART AND
SO ON.  WHAT HAPPENS WITH THEIR
ENGAGEMENT IN NATURE.  AND I
THINK YOU HAD AN INTERESTING
SEGUE ABOUT NATURE.  AND TALKED
ABOUT INTEREST
IN NATURE AS THE SHINING ARMOUR
IN WHICH GOD HAS REVEALED AND
CONCEALED AND IT'S A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT ANGLE I THINK.  AND
TALKS ABOUT THE ROLE OF THE
NATURAL WORLD.  AND NOT AS A
PHYSICAL UNIVERSE.  AND
SPECIFICALLY THE LANDSCAPE,
CLIMBING, THE WEATHER, SEASONAL
CHANGE.
SPEAKER:  I THINK THEIR
DESCRIPTION OF THE WAY IN
HOUSEKEEPING, THE WAKE IS ALMOST
AS IMPORTANT IN CHARACTER AS
EVERY HUMAN BEING.  SO THEY HAVE
A VOICE.  AND THE LAKE HAS A
PRESENCE.  AND THE LAKE WILL
COME AND INFILTRATE YOUR LIFE
AND CHANGE HOW YOU CAN LIVE.
AND I THINK THAT MODESTY IN THE
FACE OF NATURE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE READY TO CONCEDE.
SPEAKER:  I THINK OF IT IN TERMS
-- I THINK OF IT IN TERMS OF
PARTIALLY ANYWAY, THE SORT OF
THE POSITION, STEVENS AS WELL
AND EMILY DICKONSON AND THE LINE
IN HOUSEKEEPING THAT I ALWAYS
THINK OF.  IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
BOAT GOING ACROSS THE LAKE.  AND
SHE IS VERY TIRED AND CLOSES
HER EYES AND ALLOWS HER MIND TO
BECOME CO-EXTENSIVE WITH THE
DARKNESS.  AND I THINK WHEN I
READ LANDSCAPE, I READ IT AS A
PROJECTION OF CHARACTER.  IT'S
CO-EXTENSIVE WITH CHARACTER.
IT'S AN EXPERIENTIAL.  AND
LANDSCAPE DOES NOT EXIST
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE PERCEPTION
OF THE EXPERIENCE OF IT.  SO
IT'S A REFRACTIVE KIND OF
QUALITY TO IT.
SPEAKER:  SO THE OBJECTIVE
LANDSCAPE IS BEING REFRACTED
THROUGH AN EXPERIENCED SUBJECT.
AND IT BECOMES A BEAUTIFUL
LUMINOUS WAY OF RENDERING
CHARACTER.
SPEAKER:  AND ALSO I THINK
ANOTHER REALLY ENDURABLE MOMENT
FOR ME IS THE DESCRIPTION OF
ANG AND HIS FATHER AT THE GRAVE
SITE.  IT'S AN UGLY PIECE OF
LAND.  BUT THEN THEY STEP AWAY
AND IT BECOMES BEAUTIFUL.  WHICH
I AM AWAKE.
SPEAKER:  SETTING THE MEANS AND
ARRIVING AND CREATING SCHEMES OF
LIGHT.
SPEAKER:  THAT WAS AN AMAZING
MOMENT.  YOU AS A SCIENTIST, HOW
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE WORLD
WITH LANDSCAPING?
SPEAKER:  I THINK OUR
RELATIONSHIP TO NATURE IS
EXTREMELY INTERESTING.
AND
COMPLICATED.  AND I THINK THAT
THERE IS ONE METAPHOR OF NATURE,
MOTHER NATURE,NATURE, THAT
NATURE IS GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
US,
MATERNAL FEELING, THAT NATURE
COMFORTS US.  AND THEN ON THE
ON THE OTHER HAND,
WE HAVE EARTHQUAKES THAT KILL
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
AND NATURAL DISASTERS.  I ALWAYS
REMEMBER BEING OUT ON THE OCEAN
IN A SMALL BOAT THE FIRST TIME
BY MYSELF WITH MY WIFE.  AND
LOOKING AROUND AND SEEING
NOTHING BUT WATER IN EVERY
DIRECTION.  NO LAND IN SIGHT.
AND I FELT LIKE I WAS IN A VAST
PLACE THAT DIDN'T CARE ABOUT ME
AT ALL.  AND THERE WAS NO SENSE
OF SUBCONSCIOUSNESS
THERE.  AND I THINK THESE ARE --
THERE IS A TENSION BETWEEN THE
TWO DIFFERENT VIEWS OF WHAT
NATURE IS AND OUR RELATIONSHIP
TO NATURE WHICH CAN BE FOUND IN
OUR LITERATURE AND OUR HISTORY.
AND ANTHROPOLOGY AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
SPEAKER:  BUT AT LEAST YOU WERE
THERE TO NOTICE THAT NOBODY
NOTICED YOU.
[LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  ALSO YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED THAT WE HAVE AN EMPTY
CHAIR ON STAGE HERE.  IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT FOR ALIJAH WHICH IS
WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN THINKING.
SO I WOULD BE HONORED AND I
THINK WE ALL WOULD BE IF
MARILYNNE ROBINSON JOINED
US ON STAGE FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
[APPLAUSE].
SO SO I THINK THAT THE IDEA NOW
IS THAT WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
REACT A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT YOU
HAVE HEARD.  OR ADD WHATEVER YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADD.
AND TAKE US WHATEVER DIRECTION
YOU WANT TO TAKE US.
SPEAKER:  I -- WELL, FIRST OF
ALL, I HAVE TO SAY THIS IS THE
MOST SELF-INDULGENT DAY I HAVE
EVER HAD.  THIS IS BETTER THAN
MOST.  WHERE YOU WERE GOING, IT
WAS FASCINATING.  AND I COULDN'T
BE MORE PLEASED.  AND I THINK
THAT YOU SAID SOMETHING VERY
DESCRIPDESCRIPTIVE AND I AM IN
MY OWN THOUGHT AND LOOK THROUGH
IT LIKE A PRISON LENS, AND YOU
KNOW, I HAVE BECOME SORT OF
DEEPLY IMMERSED IN THEOLOGY THAT
I BASICALLY INHERITED, ALTHOUGH
I WAS UNAWARE OF IT, A LITTLE
PRESBYTERIAN KNOWING NOTHING
ABOUT WHAT I WAS BEING TAUGHT.
AND THEN AGAIN I REALIZED THAT
IT WAS A SERIES OF THEOLOGY, IT
WAS AVAILABLE TO ME.  AND THAT I
FELT AS IF, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
GRANTED IT TERMS, YOU CAN FEEL
THINGS.  AND THEOLOGY HAS OTHER
THINGS.  AND THIS IS THE ONE
THAT I FIND MYSELF ENGROSSED BY.
AND A CERTAIN EMPHASIS AND ONE
OF THEM IS THE IDEA IN WHICH YOU
FIND VERY MUCH IN WRITING.
ESPECIALLY THE EARLIER ONES THAT
THE BEAUTY IS GOD.  AND
THAT IT'S AN QUESTION OF
CONSCIOUSNESS ON WHETHER OR NOT
YOU PERCEIVE THE BEAUTIFUL.  AND
AND THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT IT'S ALWAYS
SO ONE WAY OR ANOTHER TO
BE PERCEIVED.  AND SO, THE
BUILDING OF CREATION IS IMPLICIT
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO
SEE IN ORDER TO FEEL.
AND THE FURTHER YOU GO, THE
RICHNESS BECOMES APPARENT TOO.
AND A MOMENT OF INTERACTION
BETWEEN TWO TWO
PEOPLE, WHAT PASSES BETWEEN THEM
THAT COULD BE CALLED BEAUTIFUL,
YOU KNOW?  AND ANOTHER THING
THAT I LIKE VERY MUCH ABOUT IT
IS THE HUMANISM OF IT.  THE
ASSUMPTION THAT EVERY ENCOUNTER
BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE, ONE'S SELF
AND ANOTHER, IS THE QUESTION
BEING POSED BY GOD.
AND YOUR QUESTION IS, WHAT DOES
GOD WANT FROM THIS INTERACTION.
AND THE WAY IT'S ARTICULATED AS
AN IDEA, THE OTHER IMAGE OF GOD
VIRTUALLY IS GOD AND ALL
INTERACTIONS HAVE
THEOLOGICAL WAYS.  THE OTHER IS
GOD.  THE OTHER IS CHRIST.  FROM
THE POINT OF VIEW OF MAKING
INQUIRIES OF YOUR EXPERIENCE
INTO A HUMAN BEING,
THERE IS ALMOST NO MORE
RADICALLY ILLUMINATING QUESTION
THAN WHAT WOULD GOD WANT FROM
THE SITUATION?  BECAUSE AS IT'S
ARTICULATED, GOD EITHER IS THE
OTHER PERSON OR IS VERY DEEPLY
SYMPATHETIC WITH THE OTHER
PERSON, YOU KNOW, AND IT'S KIND
OF AN AESTHETIC, ETHICAL
AESTHETIC THAT IS VERY MOVING TO
ME AND THAT, YOU KNOW, THESE
ARE PROBABLY THE TWO ASSUMPTIONS
THAT COME OUT OF MY OWN
RELIGIOUS BACKGROUND OR THEOLOGY
THAT I FIND TO BE MOST USEFUL
TO ME AS A NOVELIST.
SPEAKER:  VERY GOOD.  VERY GOOD.
SO ALTHOUGH ELEMENTS OF WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM THE PANEL UP HERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT TO PUSH
BACK ON IN ANY WAY?  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW.
SPEAKER:  IT COMES DOWN TO WHAT
YOU CALL REAL.  IF YOU LOOK AT
SOMETHING WITH AN INTENSE VALUE
INCLUDING THE REALITY OF
PLAYING, BEAUTY IS THE THING
THAT EXISTS ALSO.  AND THEY HAVE
THE LEVEL OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
COMPLICATES THE IDEA THAT
CHANGES IN AN
INCREDIBLY RICH WAY.
SPEAKER:  SO I AGREE
THAT NATURE IS BEAUTIFUL.  BUT
YOU
MENTIONED REALITY.  AND
SCIENTISTS DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT REALITY IS.
SPEAKER:  I KNOW.
[LAUGHTER].
THERE ARE BEAUTIFUL THINGS ABOUT
IT.
SPEAKER:  THERE ARE
SPEAKER:  THERE ARE BEAUTIFUL
THINGS ABOUT IT.  I THINK
PHILOSOPHERS, IF ANYBODY KNOWS
WHAT REALITY IS, IT MIGHT BE
PHILOSOPHERS.  SCIENTISTS REALLY
DON'T CLAIM TO KNOW WHAT
REALITY IS.  SCIENTISTS -- WHAT
WE KNOW AS SCIENTISTS
IS THE READINGS OF METERS AND
WHAT SCIENCE IS ABOUT FOR US IS
THE ABILITY TO PREDICT WHERE
THAT NEEDLE IS GOING TO GO WHEN
YOU HOOK IT UP TO A CERTAIN
ELECTRICAL CIRCUIT.
SPEAKER:  I THINK YOU'RE TOO
MODEST.
SPEAKER:  WELL, WE HAVE
THEORIES.  BEAUTIFUL THEORIES.
MATHEMATICALLY BEAUTIFUL
THEORIES THAT TRY TO PREDICT
WHERE THAT NEEDLE IS GOING TO
GO.  AND THOSE THEORIES HAVE
INTERNAL BEAUTIES.  BUT
ULTIMATELY, WE'RE NOT SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT REALITY.
REALITY, TO ME, IS A VERY
ABSTRACT CONCEPTION THAT ALL WE
REALLY KNOW IS OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH THE WORLD.
SPEAKER:  YOU KNOW, I MEAN I
AGREE THAT REALITY IS VERY
ELUSIVE AND APPEARS TO BE ON THE
SCALE.  YOU KNOW, BUT IF THAT
IS TRUE, THEN IF YOU SHOW A
THEORY TO ANOTHER SCIENTIST, AND
HE SAYS THAT IS NOT ELEGANT, HE
HAS MADE A STATEMENT THAT THAT
HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH REALITY,
RIGHT?  BEAUTIFUL, THAT HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH REALITY.
SPEAKER:  NO, I'M NOT, I'M
TOTALLY IN AGREEMENT WITH YOU
THAT SCIENTIFIC THEORIES CAN BE
BEAUTIFUL. AS WELL AS THE
OBJECTS THEY DESCRIBE.  BUT WHAT
SCIENCE HAS FOUND REMARKABLY IS
THAT THE THEORIES THAT WE HUMAN
BEINGS DEEM ELEGANT, HAPPENED
TO BE THE ONES THAT AGREE MOST
CLOSELY WITH WHERE THAT NEEDLE
IS GOING TO POINT ON THE VOTE
METER.  AND THEN A SCIENTIST
SAYS TO ANOTHER SCIENTIST, THAT
THEORY IS NOT ELEGANT.  I DON'T
THINK THAT SHE MEANS THAT THE
THEORY DOESN'T CORRESPOND TO
REALITY.  BUT I THINK THAT THE
THEORY IS NOT GOING TO AGREE
WITH EXPERIMENT.  BECAUSE WE
HAVE FOUND THAT ELEGANCE IN OUR
AESTHETIC JUDGMENTS SEEM TO
ACCORD WITH THE BEHAVIOR OF
NATURE.  WHICH IS A MIRACLE IN
ITSELF.
SPEAKER:  I LOVE YOUR LANGUAGE.
[LAUGHTER].  BUT IF YOU CAN'T
USE THE WORD BEAUTY, AND
MUTUALLY INTELLIGENT AND YOU
HAVE THE PREDICTIVE POWER IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU WANT TO THINK,
THEN IT EXISTS.
SPEAKER:  I CERTAINLY
AGREE.
[LAUGHTER].  WELL, IT EXISTS IN
THE SENSE THAT
VARIOUS PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT THE
PAINTING, LET'S SAY THE MONA
LISA OR SOME OTHER PAINTING THAT
WE KNOW,
PICASSO, MINOT, AND FEEL THAT
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.  OR YOU READ ONE
OF YOUR NOVELS AND YOU GET A
CONSENSUS THAT IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT MEANS THE
BEAUTY EXISTS AS AN ABSTRACT
CONCEPT OUT THERE IN THE
UNIVERSE, THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
I DON'T KNOW.  BUT CERTAINLY IF
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE CAN
AGREE THAT A
PARTICULAR THING IS BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S A DISCIPLINED THOUGHT, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT THEORY WON'T
WORK, IT IS NOT BEAUTIFUL.
I MEAN, THAT'S NOT JUST AN
AESTHETIC STATEMENT.  IT'S A
PREDICTION.
SPEAKER:  IT IS.  AGAIN, I THINK
IT GOES BACK TO THE REMARKABLE
FACT THAT OUR AESTHETIC SENSE,
WHICH IS WHAT WE CONSIDER
BEAUTIFUL, SEEMS TO ACCORD WITH
THE WORTH OF NATURE.  BY AND
LARGE, THE THEORIES THAT WE HAVE
THOUGHT WERE BEAUTIFUL TURNED
OUT TO BE THE RIGHT ONES.  AND
WHEN I SAY RIGHT, IN A SENSE
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO PREDICT
WHERE THE NEEDLE GOES ON THE
BOAT METER.
SPEAKER:  APART FROM THE
QUESTION OF PREDICTABILITY AND
SO ON.  THERE IS ANOTHER WAY IN
WHICH THE PHILOSOPHER OF SCIENCE
TALKS ABOUT THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE ARE HAVING CALLED EMERGE
EMERGENT REALITY AND FROM THE
PHENOMENON THAT THEY OCCUR IN
THE NATIONAL WORLD, THERE ARE
WISE THINGS LIKE BEAUTY AND WISE
THINGS LIKE CONSCIOUSNESS AND
MIND.  WHICH ON SOME ACCOUNTS
ARE ELUCERY AND THAT IS A
CERTAIN VERSION OF THEORY AS IT
PLAYS ITSELF OUT IN PHILOSOPHY
DEBATES ABOUT SCIENCE.  AND
ANOTHER THOUGHT IS REALITY.
THEY EMERGE FROM THE ACTUALITIES
OF PHYSICAL PROCESSES.  ARE YOU
EMERGENT BY ANY CHANCE OR
ANTIEM
ANTIEMEANTIEMERGENT?
SPEAKER:  NO, I AGREE WITH THAT,
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
PROPERTIES OF NATURE THAT CANNOT
BE PUT WITH ALL OF THE PIECES.
BUT WHEN YOU PUT EVERYTHING
TOGETHER, YOU GET SOMETHING THAT
IS QUALITATIVELY DIFFERENT AND
NOT JUST QUANTITATIVELY.
SPEAKER:  AND WHAT ABOUT YOU
WITH THE BEAUTY OF THE
EMERGENT PROPERTIES?
[LAUGHTER].
SO I WANT TO SAY AT THIS POINT,
WE ACTUALLY HAVE MICROPHONES
MICROPHONES SET UP AND IN THE
INTEREST, WE WOULD LIKE TO FIND
OUT FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK QUESTIONS OF MS. ROBINSON OR
THE PANEL, IF YOU CAN LINE UP
BETWEEN THE TWO MICS HERE AND WE
WILL GO BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE TWO AISLES.  MAKE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION.  WE ARE SORT OF A
THIRD OF THE WAY UP THE AISLE.
AND WE WILL GET TO AS MANY AS WE
CAN IN THE NEXT 20 MINUTES OR
SO.  IT WOULD
BE INTERESTING DOING THAT.  IF
ANYONE WANTS TO COME DOWN.  A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE
WE HAVE APPROACHING.  I WILL
START OVER HERE.  STAGE RIGHT.
SPEAKER:  HELLO.  THIS IS LOUD.
HI, I REALLY HAVE BEEN ENJOYING
THIS CONVERSATION.  THANK YOU SO
MUCH.  I WANT TO GO BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT PAUL SAID, ABOUT
A TEACHER, MS. ROBINSON, THE
VIRTUE NATURE AND BELIEF.  AND I
WANT TO CONNECT THAT TO THE
NATURE OF BEAUTY.  DO YOU FEEL
THAT EXPERIENCING BEAUTIFUL
OBJECTS, THINGS, MAKES
US BETTER PEOPLE?
SPEAKER:  I THINK THAT WE ARE
MADE BETTER BY BEING ATTENTIVE
TO BEAUTIES IN FORMS THAT ARE
NOT YET THOUGHT AS BEAUTIFUL.  I
THINK IT'S MUCH MORE A HABIT OF
MIND THAT IS CALLED FOR
DISCIPLINING ONE'S ATTENTION
WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN CALLED
BEAUTIFUL.
SPEAKER:  RIGHT THERE.
SPEAKER:  IN
TERMS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE SPIRITUAL AND
WRITING.  WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL, ONE OF MY PAPERS WAS
ABOUT ROBERT GRAVES.
AND THE WHITE
GODDESS, THIS WHOLE CONCEPT
THAT ARTISTS ARE NEARLY CONDUIT
AND SPIRITUAL.
AND THAT EITHER WE WORK AT IT OR
WE ARE CHOSEN.  HOW MUCH DO YOU
FEEL THAT YOUR -- THAT YOU
KNOW, SORT OF THE
SPIRITUALITY IN THIS, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I WOULD WRITE MUSIC.  YOU
USED TO BE A DRUMMER IN A BAND
AND SO ON, THINGS HAPPEN THAT
YOU DON'T PLAN AHEAD.  AND THEY
COME COME OUT IN THE STORY.  AND
IT SORT OF TAKES ON A PIECE OF
ITS OWN.
AND YOU LOSE YOURSELF.  YOU
KNOW, YOU DON'T START OFF WITH
THIS IS WHAT I AM GOING TO SAY.
BUT YOU LOSE YOURSELF IN THAT.
AND HOW MUCH DOES THAT HAPPEN IN
TERMS OF YOUR VIEW OF THE ART
OF WRITING THAT YOU ARE DEALING
WITH?
SPEAKER:  WELL, IT HAPPENS A
LOT.  YOU KNOW, I DON'T TRUST
WHAT I AM WRITING UNLESS IT
SURPRISES ME, YOU KNOW.  WHAT
IS REALLY AMAZING TO ME, I HAVE
WRITTEN TWO BOOKS AT THE
MINIMUM, THAT I CONSIDERED
DEEPLY PERSONAL.  DEEPLY
PRESENT.  I DIDN'T REALLY, UNTIL
I GOT A HOLD OF THE AGENT, I
DIDN'T THINK THAT I WOULD
PUBLISH, I JUST, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU SEE THESE THINGS THAT HAPPEN
TO THE WORLD WITH LUCK AND
WITH, YOU KNOW, HEALTH.  YOU
THANK GOD THAT YOU ACTUALLY SAID
SOMETHING THAT
RESONATES AMONG MANY PEOPLE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU WISH
YOU ARTICULATED BETTER.
AND I FEEL THAT I WRITE
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T TRULY
CONTROL AND I CAN JUST FEEL THAT
THERE IS A LIGHTNESS THAT IS
EMERGING OUT OF WHAT I DO.  AND
YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE, YOU KNOW,
RECOGNIZE THAT DURING THE WHOLE
PROCESS, I AM WRITING SOMETHING
THAT YOU HAVEN'T READ BEFORE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S AN ASSUMPTION.  I
THINK IT'S THE FEELING THAT YOU
HAVE WHEN HAVING SOMETHING PASS
THROUGH YOU IS VERY MUCH A
RESULT OF THE FACT THAT YOU
LIVED VERY MUCH MORE DEEPLY IN A
CULTURE THAN YOU REALIZE THAT
YOU DO OR YOU LIVE IN A HUMAN
COMMUNITY MORE DEEPLY THAN YOU
REALIZE.  AND YOU CAN REALLY
TALK TO PEOPLE IN A WAY THAT IS
MUCH MORE INWARD THAN YOU WOULD
EVER ANTICIPATE.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  I HAVE A
TOUGH ONE I THINK.  I HAVE A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS AN ATHEIST
ATHEIST AND
HE SAYS IT CAN BE BOILED DOWN
TO WHAT CAN BE DONE.  AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IN THE BIBLE IS
DISCERNING WHAT GOD'S WILL IS.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SCIENCE,
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU DON'T MAKE A
HECK OF A LOT OF DISTINCT
BETWEEN HOW MUCH YOU APPLY
BEAUTY TO GOOD AND EVIL AND
TRAGEDY WITH PERSEVERANCE IN
YOUR NOVELS.  SO THE QUESTION IS
HOW DO
YOU DISCERN GOD'S WILL?
[LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  WELL, YOU KNOW, I
CLING TO BASIC PROHIBITIONS.  NO
IDOLATRY, NO STEALING, NO
KILLING.  BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
AGAIN, THIS IS JUST -- MY LIFE
SURPRISES ME ALL THE TIME.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT HAVE KEPT
MY INTEREST, AND THINGS THAT I
WANT TO DO.  AND I DO THEM.  AND
THEY SATISFY THE DO-NO HARM
ETHIC.  AND NATURE CONTEXT
INSIDE.  AND I HOPE THEY ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE WORD OF GOD.
AND I FIND THAT TO BE A VERY
PLEASING IDEA.  YOU KNOW, WHO
KNOWS.
SPEAKER:  DID I IMAGINE THIS OR
DID YOU BOIL DOWN THE BIBLE
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENTLY AT ONE
POINT TO CUT IT OUT?
SPEAKER:  THE NATION SO
SERIOUSLY RAGED TOGETHER.
[LAUGHTER].
DISCERNING GOD'S WILL.  WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THE BOOK AT
ALL.  I AM WONDERING IF YOU
MIGHT SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
ABOUT THAT.
BOOK IN MY CAREER CALLED
"MOTHER COUNTRY" WHICH IS ABOUT
THE PROCESSING PLANT ON THE
COAST OF ENGLAND THAT HAS MADE
THE IRISH SEA THE MOST
RADIOACTIVE BODY OF WATER IN THE
WORLD AND IT'S A WHOLE INDUSTRY
THAT INVOLVES BUILDING WASTE
THAT CANNOT BE STORED OVER TIME.
AND MODERATED REACTORS AND THEY
SELL THEM ALL OVER
THE WORLD AND THINGS COME BACK
TO THE COAST OF ENGLAND TO BE
STRIPPED DOWN INTO A FORM AS THE
WASTE WOULD DO OTHERWISE AND
CAN'T BE STORED LIKE THE WATER
REACTOR WASTE HAVE BEEN
SO FAR.  SO IN ANY CASE, THEY
STRIP THESE THINGS DOWN AND SO
ON, A GREAT DEAL OF WASTE, AND
URANIUM, ET CETERA, AND
ISOTOPES.  AND WHATEVER, AS OF
THIS SYSTEM THAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON SINCE THE 50S, GO SIT DOWN
THE PIPELINE BY THE IRISH SEA.
AND THIS HAS HAPPENED FOR SO
LONG AT SUCH SCALE THAT IT HAS
AFFECTED THE
SCANDAVANAVIAN COUNTRIES,
ICELAND, SO ON.  IN ENGLAND, GOT
RESPECTABLE SOURCES LIKE THE
LONDON TIMES THAT THIS WAS GOING
ON.  AND I WROTE A BOOK ABOUT
IT.  PEOPLE IN ENGLAND READ IT
AND THEY TALK TO ME ABOUT IT.
AND OF COURSE IT DOES COME FROM
PLACES.  AND PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE NOT ATTRACTED
TO THE SUBJECT.
THEY WOULD RATHER -- THEY DON'T
WANT TO KNOW THIS IS GOING ON
VERY NEAR DEATH COTTAGE.  SO
THAT IS SUMMER FIELD.  AND I DID
FEEL I WAS RELIGIOUSLY
OBLIGATED TO WRITE THAT BOOK.
SPEAKER:  EACH OF YOU HAS USED
THE WORD BELIEF MORE THAN ONCE
IN THIS REALLY WONDERFUL AND
LIVELY CONVERSATION AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD ORTHODOX
UNDERSTANDING, AN EXTENT TO A
PROPOSITIONAL STATEMENT.  I
BELIEVE IN GOD THE FATHER, ALL
MIGHTY HEAVEN AND EARTH AND SO
ON.  I AM WONDERING IF YOU CAN
SAY MORE ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN BELIEF AND STORY, OR
PERHAPS FAITH AND NARRATIVE THAT
COMPLICATES BELIEF A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
SPEAKER:  I THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T HAVE A CREED SORT
OF BELIEF.  YES, THERE IS CREED
WITHOUT DIFFICULTY.  BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, I DON'T FEEL BELIEF
AT ALL AS IF IT WAS ITEMIZED AND
THERE WERE BOXES THAT I HAD TO
CHECK OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO BASICALLY IT'S QUESTIONING,
YOU KNOW, WHAT IS IN THIS
MOMENT?  WHAT IS IN THIS EVENT?
WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT
EVERYTHING IS INCREDIBLY
PRECIOUS.  THAT NOTHING IS --
NOTHING THAT HAPPENED HOWEVER,
ININEXPLICABLE IS DONE WITHOUT
THE FACT THAT EVERYTHING IS
PRECIOUS.  IT'S NOT A STATE OF
OPPOSE FOR ME.  AND YOU KNOW, AS
THE CREATOR OF SOCIAL
STATEMENTS, I FIND THAT THEY ARE
HUMAN RIGHTS.  AND I WOULD SAY
IT.  AND MAYBE SOME OF THEM ARE
NOT EXACTLY ON THE FRONT.  YOU
KNOW, THAT'S FINE WITH ME.  YOU
KNOW.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  YOU'RE WELCOME.
SPEAKER:  FIRST I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE IN THE PRESENCE OF SO MANY
OF MY FAVORITE WRITERS.  THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
CONVERSATION TOGETHER.
MARILYNNE, I HAVE READ GILIAD
MORE THAN ONCE AND DEEPLY LOVED
THE BOOK.  AND I THINK ONE OF
THE MOST POWERFUL ASPECTS OF
GILIAD IS THE COMPLICATED
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FATHERS AND
SONS IN A GENERAL SENSE.  AND I
THINK IN A LOT OF TEAMS,
LEADERS
FOCUS ON ONE OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN A FATHER
AND A SON, AND FOR ME IT'S THE
TRIO OF THE GRANDFATHER, THE
FATHER AND THE SON.  AND I THINK
HISTORY IS SO PERVASIVE IN
GILIAD AND I THINK IT'S SO
FOREIGN IN THE THREE
GENERATIONS.  THE MESSAGE IS
THAT GILIAD IS CONVEYED, AND I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO SPEAK MORE
ABOUT THAT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
HISTORY AND FATHER HOOD.  IN
THIS MOMENT IN TIME, I JUST
JUST CAN'T HELP
BUT THINK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF ABOLITIONIST
HISTORY AND THE MOMENT THAT
WE'RE IN AND THE NARROWER THINKS
SO MUCH ABOUT HIS GRANDFATHER
AND THE ABOLITION MOMENT THAT HE
IS LIVING IN.  AND HE IS LIVING
IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOMENT.
SPEAKER:  WHEN I WENT TO IOWA --
I ALWAYS LIVED EITHER IN IDAHO
OR MASSACHUSETTS.  I WAS ALWAYS,
YOU KNOW, ONE END OF THE
COUNTRY OR ANOTHER.  AND I WAS
IN IOWA AND I WANTED TO KNOW
WHAT THE HISTORY OF THE PLACE
WAS, AND WHAT THE CULTURE OF THE
PLACE WAS.  AND EVIDENTLY,
IOWANS WOULD SAY THEY HAVE NO
HISTORY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN ONE
ROOM FOR THREE HOURS WITHOUT
HAVING A HISTORY.  AND DOING
ALL KINDS OF PRIMARY RESEARCH IN
THE 19TH CENTURY.  AND SO I
FOUND OUT THAT THEY HAVE THE
FORGOTTEN HISTORY OF THE LITTLE
TOWNS ON WHAT WAS IN THE
FRONTIER, THEY ESTABLISHED IN
ORDER TO INFILTRATE AN ETHICAL
ABOLITIONISM IN THE U.S.  VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT THAT.  AND THEY
TEND TO BE BASED AROUND.  AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT STRUCK ME
WHEN I MOVED TO THE U.S. WERE
LANDSCAPES AND COLONIES AND/OR
CHURCHES, THESE PEOPLE WOULD BUY
FROM THE GOVERNMENT, IT WAS
VERY CHEAP.  AND THEY WOULD
BUILD A COLLEGE.  THEY HAD
PATRONS.
WOULD SELL THE PLACE.  AND
PEOPLE MOVED WEST AND WANTED TO
BE NEAR A COLLEGE OR CHURCH AND
THE PROPERTY VALUE WOULD GO UP
AND USE IT TO UNDER WRITE WHAT
THEY HAVE SPOKEN OF.  AND START
NEW TOWNS WITH NEW COLLEGES AND
NEW CHURCHES AND YOU HAVE WHAT
IS CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT FROM
AMERICAN HISTORY.  AND
ANTI-SLAVERY MIDDLE WEST THAT
PRODUCED PEOPLE LIKE LINCOLN AND
GRANT AND SHERMAN AND SO ON.
AND ALSO TREMENDOUS UNION ARMY
IN THE PERIOD.  IN THE LATEST
STAGES OF THE WAR.  SO YOU KNOW,
SO I SAW FOR MYSELF, A
REMARKABLE HISTORY OF VERY, VERY
GREAT
IMPORTANCE.  YOU KNOW.
WITHIN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.  AND GOING THROUGH THE
SCHOOLS.  AND HAVE MANY OF THE
SORT OF CULTURAL QUALITIES THAT
CAME FROM THEM.  FOR EXAMPLE, NO
SEGREGATION IN SCHOOL AND
ANTI-SEGREGATION LAWS AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS.  SO ANYWAY, THE
PHENOMENON OF THE HISTORICAL
FORGETFULNESS OF THAT LEVEL,
HAVE ALL OF THE PEOPLE, PEOPLE
OUT THERE DOING ADMIRABLE
THINGS, IF WE HAD PERSISTED IN
THEM, WOULD HAVE SAVED ALL KINDS
OF MISERY AND REINVENTIONS OF
WHEELS AND SO
ON.  I MEAN, PEOPLE ACTUALLY
FELT WHEN I WAS A CHILD, THAT
INTEGRATING
SCHOOLS WAS A NOVEL IDEA.  AND
THE COUNTRY HAS DONE IT BEFORE.
AND THE CULTURE OF FORGETFULNESS
IS THAT IT CAN BE A DEVASTATING
LOSS.  AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS A MAJOR SUBJECT
IN THE GULIAD NOVEL.
SPEAKER:  WE'RE DOWN IN THE LAST
FEW MINUTES.  AND PERHAPS WE
CAN TAKE IN IN TURN, WE HAVE
THREE ON THIS SIDE, TWO ON THAT.
PERHAPS IF WE CAN TAKE THE THREE
FOLKS ROUND UP OVER HERE AND IF
YOU CAN ASK YOUR QUESTIONS IN
TURN AND WE WILL STORE THEM UP
AND SEE WHAT PARTS OF THEM
EITHER MARILYNNE ROBINSON OR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL WOULD LIKE
TO ANSWER.  WE'LL START WITH
YOU.
SPEAKER:  SURE.  THANK YOU FOR
ALL BEING HERE TONIGHT.  IT WAS
LOVELY.  EARLIER IN THE
CONVERSATION, SOMEONE MENTIONED
GULIAD AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
IMAGINE GULIAD IN A TIME AFTER
TIME MAGAZINE HAS IMAGINED IF
GOD IS DEAD.  AND DOESN'T
PERCEIVE TOO FAR IN THE
DISTANCE.  I WONDER IN A LOT OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS WHAT SORT OF
SPIRITUAL CONSCIOUSNESS HAS
BEEN, AND IF IT HAS BEEN LOST,
LOST, HOW DO WE ARTICULATE THAT
AS MORE THAN JUST DECLINING
CHURCH ATTENDANCE?  ALONG WITH
THAT QUESTION, WHERE DO YOU FIND
THE MOST INTERESTING COMPELLING
ARTICULATION IN FAITH AND
IMAGINATION MOVING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY IN OUR PUBLIC
CONSCIENCE?
SPEAKER:  I ACTUALLY
WANTED TO ASK, I WAS VERY -- I
WAS VERY INTRIGUED BY THE
PREMISE -- ONE OF THE PREMISES
THAT AMERICA HAS A GENERAL MORE
SOCIAL ASPECT THAN GREAT BRITAIN
AND GOES INTO THE HISTORY OF
SOCIAL REFORM.
AND I WAS WONDERING HOW YOU CAN
INTERPRET SOME POLITICAL EVENTS
IN AMERICA AND THE AMERICAN
SOCIAL
NORMS THAT YOU INVESTIGATED IN
THAT THAT BOOK.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  THIS HAS
BEEN A REALLY ENLIGHTENING
CONVERSATION IN MANY WAYS.  MY
QUESTION IS PROMPT BY THE
GENTLEMAN WHO SHARED THE BELIEF
AND RESPONSE.  AND IN MY OWN
LIFE, AND MY OWN RESEARCH, I
THINK ABOUT RELIGIOUS PRACTICE
MORE THAN I DO ABOUT RELIGIOUS
BELIEF.  AND WHEN YOU SPEAK
ABOUT BELIEF AS A PLACE, I'M
WONDERING ABOUT PRACTICE.  I'M
WONDERING ABOUT MOMENTS WHEN
BELIEF FILTERS.  AND I'M ALSO
WONDERING ABOUT THE WAYS IN
WHICH PEOPLE ENACT AND LIVE OUT
THEIR COMMITMENT AND THOSE
ACTIONS AND JUST WHAT KINDS OF
CONNECTIONS YOU WOULD MAKE
BETWEEN BELIEF AND PRACTICE AND
WHAT ABSENCE MIGHT LOOK LIKE
SOMETIMES IN THE FAULT OF
BELIEF.
THINK THAT -- I THINK OF MYSELF
AS FILTERING.
IT HAPPENS TO BE TRUE THAT YOU
KNOW, THIS SORT OF AESTHETIC
ABOUT THE PHYSICAL AND THE
SCIENTIFIC WAYS I UNDERSTAND,
IT'S VERY SATISFYING TO ME.  IT
SEEMS CORRESPONDING TO ME.  AND
YOU KNOW, IF I ASSIGN MYSELF NOT
POSITIONED TO IT, I DON'T BRING
IT.  I DON'T KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I DON'T TURN.
I THINK THAT ANY RELIGION
TEACHES PRACTICE.  AND I THINK
CERTAINLY CHRISTIANITY TEACHES
GENEROSITY AND COMPASSION.  AND
THAT IS THE ESSENTIAL PRACTICE I
THINK IN IN BOTH OF THOSE
FAITHS.  AND I THINK FAITH IS
REJUVENATED BY THE PRACTICES
THAT ARE SIMPLE TO IT LIKE
COMPASSION.
SPEAKER:  AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW,
IN AMERICA, THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A VERY COMPLEX RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THEM THAT IS ECONOMIC
AS MUCH AS ANYTHING.  IF YOU
LOOK AT LAWS FOR THE WORKING
CLASS IN THE 19TH CENTURY
ENGLAND AND LOOK AT THE LAWS
THAT HAVE CONTROLLED THE
ENSLAVED PEOPLE IN THE SOUTH.
THEY ARE
ALMOST IDENTICAL.  YOU KNOW,
THERE IS A HISTORY OF
EXPLOITATION OF THE WORKING
CLASS THAT IN ENGLAND, I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE USED TO TALK
ABOUT WAGE DISPLACEMENT.
AND THEY HAD EVERY REASON TO
CALL IT THAT.  THE MOVEMENT --
THE KIND OF ECONOMICS THAT I
CRITICIZED IN ANOTHER COUNTRY AS
BEING BRITISH IS SIMPLY THE
IDEA THAT EVERYTHING AT BEST IS
REDUCED TO LIQUID MONEY.  THAT
IS CAPITALISTS.  YOU KNOW, YOU
SQUEEZE THE MONEY OUT OF HERE
AND YOU CAN PUT IT THERE.
SQUEEZE THE MONEY OUT OF THERE
AND PUT IT THERE.  YOU KNOW, IF
THINGS START FILLING NATIONAL
ASSETS, WE WOULD BE TAKING ON
ECONOMIC ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE
VERY CLOSE TO OUR BRITISH
ORIGINS.  AND THEIR IDEA THAT
ACTUALLY CAPITALS, YOU KNOW,
MARX'S WORD IS THE ULTIMATE
PERFORM OF PROPERTY.  AND WITH
ANYTHING ELSE IS BASICALLY
REDUCIBLE TO -- IT HAS THE VALUE
OF WHAT CAN BE REDUCED TO IT IN
TERMS OF LIQUID WEALTH.  THAT'S
WHY YOU HAVE THINGS IN THE
FIELD.  AND MY CONCLUSION, IT
GENERATES A GREAT DEAL OF MONEY
AND THE COST OF IT IS NOT FELT
BY THE PEOPLE WHO APPRECIATE THE
WEALTH THAT IS
GENERATED BY IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT ASSUMPTION,
YOU KNOW, ALL SORTS OF BARRIERS
GO DOWN.
SPEAKER:  SO FROM THE FIRST
QUESTION, I TOOK ONE ELEMENT OF
IT WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
INTRIGUING.  DO YOU FEEL HAVING
SET YOUR NOVELS AS WE SAID IN
THE VERY OUTSET, IN THE DISTANT
BUT NOT TOO DISTANT PATH BEFORE
GOD ENTERED THE CULTURE, HAVE
WE LOST OUR SPIRITUAL IDENTITIES
SINCE THEN?  OR IS IT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE SAME STORY?
DO YOU SEE A
DISCONTINUITY THERE AND WHERE DO
YOU SEE HOPE IN THE ELEMENT OF
TODAY'S CULTURE?
SPEAKER:  WELL, YOU KNOW, I HAVE
BEEN AROUND IN EUROPE QUITE A
BIT AND IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND IN EUROPE INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH, I'M ASKED ABOUT THEOLOGY
AND NEWSPAPER INTERVIEWS ABOUT
THEOLOGY.  I HAVE COME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT
THE SECULARISM IN THE WESTERN
PART OF THE WORLD IS ONE-EIGHTH
OF AN INCH DEEP.
AND IT COMES PROFOUNDLY
NATURALLY TO KEEP AND SIMPLY
INVOLVES, YOU KNOW, TO ENGAGE A
KIND OF, YOU KNOW, THINKING THAT
PEOPLE WILL CALL NAIVE AND WE
ARE SO TERRIFIED OF THAT WORD.
SO I DON'T THINK, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE OTHER CONVERSATIONS
THAT LEVEL, YOU KNOW, GOD IS
DEAD AND THAT KIND OF STUFF.
AND OF COURSE, YOU KNOW, TO
SPEAK OF THE RADICAL EVENT OF
CRUCIFIXION, HE USES THE THE
SENTENCE GOD IS DEAD.  AND THE
RELIGIOUS CONTENT BEFORE IT WAS
MADE INTO SOMETHING ELSE.
AND OUT OF THE EVENT, SAYING TO
THE PUBLIC, SHHH, WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO PRETEND THAT WE
DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT ANYMORE.
AND I THINK IT'S HUMAN NATURE TO
SAY SOMETHING KEPT US GOING TO
EXPAND IN A WAY.  I DON'T THINK
THAT'S DESCRIPTIVE OF IT AT ALL.
THE LAST FEW QUESTIONS.  AND
THEN IF WE HAVE TIME TO SAY A
PREVIOUS BRIEF SOMETHING.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU ALL FOR A
WONDERFUL SESSION AND A SERIES
OF POWERFUL MOVING NOVELS.  I --
I HEARD YOU ALL TALK QUITE A BIT
ABOUT SOME OF THE VISIONARY
ASPECTS OF FAITH AND BELIEF AND
THE ROLE OF BEAUTY IN
PARTICULAR.  ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS STRIKING TO ME IN THE
GILIAD TRILOLOGY IS THE THE
DIFFERENT STRING OF THOUGHT, THE
USE OF TOTAL DEPRAVITY AND THE
WAY THAT JACK PERCEIVES OF HIS
OWN EXPERIENCES AND FEARS MIGHT
BE CONDEMNED AND THE RAW
DIFFICULTY THAT ESPECIALLY AIMS
AND FATHER HAVE IN TRYING AND
NOT QUITE SUCCEEDING AT
FORGIVING HIM.  NOT PLAYING --
NOT BEING ABLE, PERHAPS, TO PLAY
THE ROLE OF THE FATHER AND THE
SON THE WAY THEY WANT TO.  I AM
WONDERING IF YOU CAN SPEAK A BIT
TO THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
VISIONARY ASPECTS OF THE
THOUGHTS AND THE MORAL DRAMA
THAT WE FIND IN THE SECOND HALF
OF
GILIAD.
SPEAKER:  WELL, THERE IS NOTHING
BUT FORGIVENESS.  THE WHOLE
THEOLOGY IS BASED ON FORGIVING
JACK.  JACK DOESN'T FORGIVE
HIMSELF.  THE, YOU KNOW,
EVERY THEOLOGY HAS COMPLEX
WORKING PARTS,
YOU KNOW, AND THE IDEA OF
FALLING SHORT IS
I THINK INTRINSIC IN EVERY
THEOLOGY AND TO SEE AND
EXPERIENCE BEAUTIFUL
DEMONSTRATIONS OF BELIEF AND
FORGIVENESS, DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT YOU ARE ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?  SO
BASICALLY ABOUT WHAT I CONSIDER
TO BE A PHENOMENON OF FAITH THAT
IS VERY GENERAL IN RELIGIOUS
TRADITIONS.  AND AT LEAST THE
ULTIMATE BENEFIT THAT IS REALLY
NOT UP TO HIM.  YOU KNOW, HE
CAN'T
KNOW.  AND YOU KNOW, IT'S A NEW
ROLL OF THE DICE WHEN YOU TALK
TO SOMEONE.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  OKAY.
LAST QUESTION BRIEFLY.
SPEAKER:  THIS QUESTION IS FOR
ANYONE ON THE PANEL.  YOU
PROVIDED ME WITH A STORY OF
ANOTHER WRITER WHICH OCCURRED
RECENTLY, THE WRITER WHO LOST
THE ABILITY TO PRODUCE
TESTOSTERONE AND THESE TWO MEN
EXPERIENCES EVERYTHING AS BEING
BEAUTIFUL BUT IN A -- HE
DESCRIBES IT AS A COMPLETELY
OBJECTIVE.  AND HE JUST STOPS
JUDGE
JUDGING THINGS.  HE WOULD SEE A
CRACK IN THE SIDEWALK AND SAY
THAT IS BEAUTIFUL.  AND BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, HE ALSO LOST ALL
OF THAT MOTIVATION TO DO
ANYTHING AS WELL.  AND I WAS
JUST WONDERING IF MAYBE THIS
PRESENTS THE KIND OF METAPHOR
ABOUT A CERTAIN TENSION BETWEEN
NOT JUDGING THINGS AND
EXPERIENCING THINGS
AS BEAUTIFUL AS THEY ARE AND
CERTAIN TENSION WITH ACTING AND
POSING THE WORLD ON A WAY WHERE
YOU MIGHT HAVE A CERTAIN VISION
OF
BEAUTY OF YOUR OWN AND THAT
WOULD YOU ALSO WANT TO INTERACT
WITH MATERIALS OR OUTSIDE WORLD.
SPEAKER:  SO YOUR CONCERN IS
WHAT AFFECT BEAUTY MIGHT HAVE ON
AGENCY?  IT IT MIGHT
BE IN SOME WAYS TODAY
DEBILITATING.
SPEAKER:  A LACK OF JUDGMENT.
SPEAKER:  OKAY, DOES ANYBODY
WANT TO TAKE THAT?  A QUICK
RESPONSE?
SPEAKER:  WHY ME?
[LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  I JUST THINK IT'S EASY
TO BECOME HABITUATED TO
A CULTURATED THINKING AND I
THINK IT'S EASY TO BECOME
HABITUATED TO THINKING WHAT YOU
THINK IS THOUGHT.  BUT IN FACT,
IT IS NOT THINKING.  [LAUGHTER].
AGAIN.
I THINK IT'S, AT LEAST IN THE
CONTEXT OF HOW WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUTTALKING ABOUT IT
UP HERE IS THAT IT IS ON A
CERTAINLY
LEVEL, IT'S A TECHNICAL SKILL.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A MUSCLE.  YOU
HAVE TO HABITUATE YOURSELF TO
THE DISCIPLINE OF FEELING
BEAUTY.
AND THE BEAUTIFUL PARADOXICAL
KIND OF DISCIPLINE.  BECAUSE
WHAT IT IS, IS CULTIVATING THE
ABILITY TO STOP THE WILL AND
BEAUTY IN EVERYTHING YOU SEE.
AND RESERVING JUDGMENT AND NOT
ACTING AS IF YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE LOOKING AT.  AND YOU ARE
REALLY TRYING TO CULTIVATE THE
HABIT OF THE INNOCENT, YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT.
AND THE CRACK IN THE PAVEMENT IS
LIKELY TO BE QUITE BEAUTIFUL
AND HAVE ITS OWN LITTLE ECO
SYSTEM.
AND THE IDEA TOO, THAT THE
CLOSER AND THE MORE SUSTAINED
THE TENSION IS, THE MORE DEPTH
-- THE UNIVERSE IS ALL
OBSERVATION WILL ALWAYS
ACCOMMODATE WHAT DEPTHS OF
ACCOMMODATION YOU CHOOSE TO LEND
TO IT.  AND ALL HAS COME INTO
MORE AND MORE BEAUTIFUL
RESOLUTION.  AND I THINK THAT IS
WHEN YOU SEE THINGS THAT WE
TALK ABOUT A LOT, THE POSITION
AND CAUSE A BARRACK BETWEEN THE
INFINITE AND YOU CAN GO DOWN TO
THE SMALLEST TINIEST DETAIL AND
IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL, AND WILL JUST
OPEN BACK ON TO THE WHOLE
UNIVERSE IN A CERTAIN WAY.  IT'S
ALMOST LIKE A FEEDBACK.  THAT'S
JUST ME.  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  THAT SOUNDS TO BE LIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE OF
TESTOSTERONE.  [LAUGHTER].  ALL
RIGHT.  WE ARE AT THE END OF OUR
TIME.  I AM GOING TO TURN THE
PROGRAM BACK TO THE DIRECTOR OF
THE JOHN KLUGE CENTER, TED
WIDMER.  AND BEFORE I DO SO, LET
ME ASK YOU TO THANK OUR GUESTS
OF HONOR AND THE PANEL.
[APPLAUSE].
INSPIRING EVENING AND THANK YOU
FOR COMING OUT.  LET'S NOT ONLY
APPLAUSE THE PANEL MEMBERS, BUT
THE MODERATOR WHO DID SUCH A
GOOD JOB TONIGHT.
[APPLAUSE].
TWO VERY BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENTS,
WHEN YOU CAME IN WITH THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS, YOU RECEIVED A
SURVEY.  WE'LLED
GRATEFUL IF YOU CAN FILL IT
OUT.  AND GRATEFUL IF YOU CAN
FILL IT OUT.  AND ALSO, OUR
PANELISTS WILL BE SIGNING BOOKS
IN THE WHITTALL PAVILION NEXT
DOOR.  THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.